بريطانيا الخاليه من المهاجرين غير
النظاميين هدف تسعى اليه الحكومه الحاليه
رغم الانتقادات لنهجها في تحقيقه مشروع
قانون تعتزم الحكومه تقديمه يتضمن منع
قبول اللجوء اي شخص يدخل البلاد بطرق غير
نظاميه خصوصا من يصلون على متن قوارب
صغيره عبر القناه للانجليزي
الاجراءات المقترحه تشمل احتجاز وترحيل
المهاجرين المعنيين الى بلدانهم او الى
بلد ثالث تقول منظمات مدافعه عن حقوق
اللاجئين ان العديد من المهاجرين يخاطرون
بعبور القناه للانجليزي في قوارب صغيره
لان هناك القليل من الطرق الامنه
والقانونيه للوصول الى بريطانيا ويرى
منتقد خطه الحكومه انها غير اخلاقيه وغير
قابله للتطبيق تستقبل بريطانيا عددا من
طالبي اللجوء اقل من بعض الدول الاوروبيه
ففي عام 2021
استقبلت تسعه فقط من كل مئه الف مقارنه
بمتوسط الاتحاد الاوروبي البالغ سته عشر
شخصا لكل مئه الف هذا المعدل القليل
للقبول يدفع الاف المهاجرين الى سلوك طريق
وعره عبر السفر الى شمال فرنسا على امل
الانطلاق منها بحرا الى بريطانيا بحسب
احصائيات وزاره الداخليه البريطانيه وصل
اكثر من خمسه واربعين الف شخص الى
بريطانيا في العام الماضي عن طريق القوارب
بينما وصل اليها 28
في عام 2021
وثمانيه الاف وخمسمئه طالب لجوء في عام
2020 طلب اللجوء لكن تراكم اكثر من 160
الف حاله ادى الى وجود الكثيرين منهم في
مراكز مؤقته او فنادق مكتظه دون الحق في
العمل تقول الحكومه البريطانيه ان العديد
من الذين يقومون بالرحله هم مهاجرون
لاسباب اقتصاديه وليس لاجئين وتشير الى
زياده في عدد الوافدين العام الماضي من
البانيا وهي دوله اوروبيه تعتبرها
بريطانيا امنه فيما تصر جمعيات اللاجئين
على ان معظم الوافدين عبر القناه فارون من
الحرب او الاضطهاد او المجاعه في دول مثل
افغانستان وايران والعراق رحله القناه
يمكن ان تصل الى 42 كيلومترا وقد تكون اقل
خطوره من طرق الهجره عبر البحر الابيض
المتوسط لكن عشرات الاشخاص لقوا حتفهم في
القناه مخاطر لا تمنع طالبي اللجوء من
المجازفه ومحاوله عبور القناه للانجليزي
امام قله خياراتهم